>>It's actually putting
its DNA into your cells,
and so unless all your infected
cells get killed you're just going
to keep making it.
>>Teacher: So we can--
very good, amazing.
>>Narrator: Students in
Blair's class are learning
about physiology and multimedia.
>>You need to find a good picture of
an antibody binding with an antigen.
>>Narrator: When class is over
they walk just across the hall
where they study art with Jeff Robin.
>>Jeff: An easy way of making
it look three dimensional is
to give everything a little
bit of a shadow like on the arm
and on the blood, everywhere, okay?
>>Narrator: The students are working
on one project in both classes.
>>Blair: We found good sources?
>>Student: Yeah, we have
ten sources right now.
>>Narrator: And it's all about blood.
>>Gabby: All of our classmates
are studying different aspects
like the art of blood and blood in
religions and, you know, like AIDS.
>>Blair: The blood
project is something
that students will specialize in.
Doing art around it, doing
research around it and presenting
that research in an
audio-visual format on DVD.
>>What's going on here?
>>That's a fat that builds up.
>>Narrator: Students are
creating multimedia exhibits
that will be displayed
at a local art gallery
and will promote blood donation.
>>Ramona: So let me tell you a
little bit about the blood bank.
>>Narrator: San Diego Blood Bank
Director Ramona Walker visits the
class to provide background
information.
>>Ramona: Yeah?
>>Gabby: Has there ever been a time
where the blood supply
has been really low?
>>Ramona: Well you
know, yes, actually.
About three years ago-
>>Gabby: It's much more
engaging when you do it this way
and when you actually get to do
the project and create something
at the end and not only teach
ourselves, but teach the community.
>>Jeff: Maybe you could put what
it's about in that same kind
of text here, here and there-
>>Gabby: Oh I see what
you mean, okay.
>>Jeffrey: To balance it out.
>>Narrator: Robin makes sure students
get their hands on every phase
of the project guiding
them through the design
and construction of the dioramas.
>>Jeffrey: So you can come
in and come in sideways.
>>JThis is something that
I think is real life.
If they're going to get a job when
they first get out of college,
it's going to be doing
something visual.
It will be something to do with the
computer, and they're going to have
to do something for their bosses
to put together a presentation
and that's what this is about.
>>Did Blair approve
those writing things?
>>Student: Our scripts?
>>Jeffrey: Yeah.
>>Student: He hasn't
looked at it yet but I mean-
>>Jeffrey: Show it to him before
you start writing on this.
>>Narrator: This complex project
has many interlocking assignments
and deadlines to keep track of.
>>Jeffrey: It's so complicated
and planning it just making
a calendar what you're going
to do every single day for a
whole semester, with this you have
to be right on it or
all hell breaks loose.
>>Narrator: Hatch posts the
curriculum on the school's website
and students turn in their work as
part of their digital portfolio.
>>Blair: They don't hand it to me.
They post it and they keep it
in their sort of virtual locker.
The advantage of that for me is
that at the end is you're going
to see what this student did
week two, three, four, five,
six all the way down the line
so it's real process-oriented.
They'll send me a link to
their DP every two weeks.
It's the same link, but by sending it
to me they're saying they've updated
it and they're ready to be assessed.
So I assess it by going and
finding the things that are due.
That's how we communicate.
That's how I keep the
student accountable.
>>They're going to meet with
you on Wednesday for posters.
>>Jeffrey: right.
>>Blair: And then meet with me
on Thursday for visual scripts.
>>Jeffrey: Oh that's right, tomorrow-
>>Narrator: Hatch and
Robin meet every morning
to coordinate the project.
>>Rob: The fact that
we have teachers coming
in here an hour a day before their
kids is the unseen structural feature
that really makes this place work.
>>We're trying to create
an environment where all
of our adults are engaged
in and learning together.
>>Blair: You like the
way the poster is.
Therefore we have the art.
>>Jeffrey: To get him to want to
be partners with me and to do this,
I learned about iron and oxygen
so most teachers don't go out
and learn another subject
area but you have to do
that when you do this team
teaching project based learning.
>>Blair: The heart has
to pump constantly.
>>So it's important that you know
what the other guy is teaching
but that makes you a
lifelong learner as well
and then that's a good role
model for students to see.
>>Jeffrey: Yeah, I like how
it bounces back and forth.
>>Blair: I've learned a lot
about my own teaching practice
by being interdisciplinary and
thematic with another professional.
It's creative so it
keeps me on my toes.
>>For more information on what works
in public education
go to edutopia.org